hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay
I was delaying on going down in this
basement actually hang on one second I
got a I I see look how far down I have
that crank the volume to get this to
work but it was just a bit too quiet so
I'm just gonna squeeze it up just the
tiniest bit and hopefully that'll be
better for you guys alright anyway I was
delaying going down to this basement cuz
well you know why
hello haha no face in the face in the
face in the face in the face
whoops you dead okay is it nothing else
in this room doesn't look like it okay
aha
yep dip whoop zip zop Zubin it bah bah
yeah I should probably like shoot him
more oh no ahh no you don't know you
don't know yeah ah yeah and then switch
like the knife and fish moth save ammo
ah nevermind nevermind no that's a dumb
idea that's a stupid idea
okay there you are choo choo choo choo
there we go only four shots not bad Oh
what huh what what what what what I said
what Davis how many shots do you need
keep forgetting that I have like no
health Oh what huh what are you doing
what the hell
hey that one some are tougher than
others this it's the way things are
alright shotgun ammo but the only thing
down here I don't see any key the
upstairs doors is locked so I would
assume that I would have been a key or
something down here
anything check the corners nothing
yeah palm pets I don't know
I think check the corners ha nothing
okay
ah whoa missed damn it yeah too right
now head excuse me
not doing too bad ah more health ooh
what's this Desert Eagle got a different
gun ah
it is the equivocal hand cannon Wow
alright take that I'm gonna pop out nope
okay no key so it must have been in the
other area that I was debating going
towards because there were two little
passier stores locked yeah see and there
was nothing here
ah that was it it was the vent down
there
I don't like vents come at me bro
got my little Desert Eagle okay it's
dark
uh-huh all right okay
let's give this a try see where it goes
huh little hand mouth face sky head hand
hand head hog hug hug hug
Pogo dude Oh more health yay
they're actually giving me health that's
something don't want to go down there oh
I know what what is that what ah ah I
don't I don't know I don't know what it
was I heard and then Olsen ah I don't
know
Wow holy crap what's that oh there's
another one up there oh no wait that's
where I came up I'm dumb never mind
alright section D what is section D all
about seems to be a large section D
going on um I guess I'm supposed to drop
down alright
it's a long drop ow why that boxes I
can't break these damn okay all right oh
ah no no no no no boxes
I feel break your boxes ha ha
oh and Kenan like one shot in but now
I'm down to one health again fantastic
oh I just had to oh thank you thank you
how they're like barely just barely
keeping me alive
I know sometimes you know the harder
difficulties are really just there for
replayability not to be played on the
first try because then you don't know
what's gonna happen
ah another one I got a hand cannon
where'd you go did you fall aha
I see you I see you I never anything yes
there was something okay
what was that 13 clip there like a max
ammo that I can hold on this ah more
ammo thank you
was there anything else that fell on the
floor that I might have missed what was
back this way is there anything
okay door's locked okay so now we go
along
more box to murder batteries I'll take
those oh it's bright in there oh it's an
elevator huh rule number one two three
four and five all in effect huh huh Oh
Trash Can yes
yeah lots of ammo that's what I'm
talking about
always check the corners it's la ah ha
huh Oh pills huh yeah all right okay
got enough batteries less through here
no I probably wasted way too many
bullets on that but whatever you done
there uh-huh who's that there was that
this to the valve huh huh
what's going on here Oh what in the sky
nope um oh I get it up here mmm come on
come on
how odd damn it
well how do I get back up oh okay ah the
steam really really ah damn it
okay now I'm supposed to get over here
or not what the hell I can't seem to get
up there we've been not supposed to go
that direction no jump there we go okay
up there we are
hop there we are gotcha gotcha crouch ah
there you are
there we got five shots that'll do gotta
love the accuracy on these whoa oh don't
burn me don't burn me I got burnt again
where uh-huh
why can't there be a big medkit
ah damn it damn it dick good good damn
Oh hot damn this is my jam oh here we go
ah there we are taken care of now I get
back up I go over dissing dissing way in
for the happy times happy times and
don't burn to myself there we are go
town tear hunt we're good huh wait isn't
in this where I was wasn't I there
before I got in reload cuz they brought
me down to 1l ok yeah it was this is the
way I was before
ah how'd you get there what are you
doing I don't know I don't want any sir
thank you goodbye don't come again okay
didn't I
whoa-oh-aah you know wow you're
something funky was going on there
you're one of the tougher ones that face
is tough take more bullets anything in
the trash cans no no no and they
actually they're actually running me
through my ammo security
oh please please save me mr. security
all these look from the keys there we go
section D keys ah these are typical half
life control plans Oh where'd you come
from running screw you
ha cream ah screw huh no no no no no no
no aah
no no no no no no no I said no I said no
sir hey shake of my finger at you
cuz I a say no aah
three shots really shot you through the
window hmm Section B ah Oh what the heck
is section D oh I'm up here oh yeah Oh
what day it's a box
doctor I need oh it's a bot oh I can
climb up back to the vent whoa Wow okay
I'm super strong apparently not damn it
okay and just okay Wow half-life physics
were not this bad
something's going on here I'll boy jog
on
huh huh huh
oh I'll run out of batteries oh okay I
know where I got the keys now I know
where to go
huh huh huh well I got chills running up
and down my spine that Mona Lisa still
they're so creepy
what's up here okay all right
I see you ah all of you uh uh yeah yeah
yeah
what the hell yeah go get you yeah
quiet womp womp here we go wah wah wah
wah aah go crawl ah miss me
[ __ ] go [ __ ] damn it
I wasted like all my bullets on that one
I'm terrible
all right here we go ah not this
dramatic conclusion to the button press
he's gonna have to wait until next time
thank you everyone so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye-bye